what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down the top 5
things that you didn't know about Batman
so starting off our list is the way
Batman was originally designed to look
while Batman was conceived of by artist
Bob Kane writer bill finger gave us the
version of Batman that were most
familiar with today the original concept
of the Batman character as he was drawn
by Bob Kane was actually modeled heavily
after Superman
this included Batman wearing a
full-bodied red outfit similar to
Superman's cape and a set of underwear
on the outside as well as a large set of
black wings on his back when Bill Finger
was brought into the project however he
suggested the Batman work cowl with the
eyeholes missing to promote mystery and
that his wings be replaced with a cape
for gliding and that his red outfit be
replaced with a black or dark grey
outfit to allow him to blend in with the
darkness these suggestions ultimately
came to fruition with the infamous cover
of Detective Comics issue number 27 in
1939 so coming in at number 4 on our
list is Batman's cape while popular
opinion has led to the belief that bill
fingers design of Batman's cape was
modeled after Superman the cape was
actually modeled after Leonardo da
Vinci's drawing of the ornithopter a
device had actually achieved flight in
the same fashion as birds by simply just
flapping their wings while Batman does
not possess the ability to fly the
current design of his cape and ability
to glide was based off of this drive
from Leonardo da Vinci which Bill Finger
used in an effort to make Batman appear
more mysterious and terrifying to his
various foes the surrounding our list at
the number 3 spot is the cost of being
Batman since DC has never explicitly
stated how much money Batman has simply
referring to him as a millionaire and
later a billionaire the New York Post
published an article in 2008 tackling
the question of how much it would cost
for a person to become Batman after
taking into account the cost of
excavating and stocking the Batcave
creating the Batmobile the batwing as
well as the various other vehicles the
martial arts training the exercise
equipment in addition to all of the
other gadgets that were pulled together
to allow Bruce Wayne to undertake his
life of crime fighting the total was
estimated to be at a staggering three
hundred million dollars although this
does not take into account the items
that had to have been replaced over the
years
as they were either destroyed by
villains or destroyed by Batman himself
so coming in at number two is more of a
Robin facts but a little know thing you
may not have known about Dick Grayson
was that he was only supposed to appear
for a single issue when Dick Grayson was
created Bob Kane simply wanted to test
the waters to see if fans would be
receptive to a pre teenage kid fighting
alongside Batman in addition to making
Batman more lighthearted the goal also
included tapping into the youth of
America and an effort to garner more
support for the war effort during World
War two
while editor Jack Leibowitz was against
the idea of a kid fighting gangsters in
New York Detective Comics number 38 the
first appearance of Dick Grayson
actually sold two times as many copies
as any previous issues of Batman as a
result DC continued the publication's of
Batman titles with Dick Grayson as the
Robin sidekick which actually led to the
concept of superhero sidekicks as we
know them today
so number one on our list is the
question of where Gotham is located one
of the biggest questions among casual
comic fans is a location of the cities
belonging to various superheroes well
the answer to this question is that
there isn't one while the original
appearance of Batman has him fighting in
New York City itself and Batman number
four in 1940 Batman was moved to the
fictional city of Gotham but due to the
multiple reboots of DC's continuity over
the years as well as the change in
distance between Gotham and cities like
metropolis the Gotham could actually be
located in any number of places
including New York City Chicago and even
Philadelphia and truth until DC comes
out and openly states the location of
Gotham City itself in relation to some
of the bigger cities in the United
States we'll probably never know the
answer to this question
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace